we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p here's a
voicemail about a phrase that now has
become cliche because it's so ridiculous
draining the swamp and donald trump take
a listen hey David I'm really upset
without Trump is appointing all of these
big bankers big oil company people
everyone else to be a part of this
cabinet he said drain the swamp not
completely not what he's doing but my
question is who are some people who are
non-corrupt conservatives who could be
appointed to his cabinet that would do a
good job from a Republican point of view
yeah this is this is a fair question a
you know to say that i don't wanna name
names and imply that i completely agree
with these people but like for example
when Trump was talking to Mitt Romney
about the Secretary of State position
that at least make some sense again like
the question is within the Republican
worldview Mitt Romney wakes MIT makes
way more sense in terms of actually
doing things that represent people's
interest may be in it in the wrong way
maybe in an ineffective way but at least
people's interest instead of uh the oil
industry mit romney made more sense than
rex tillerson uh it would be interesting
to see somebody who's a little bit more
small government in not a completely
insane as insane of a way as some of the
people like rick perry so for example
like a rand paul would be interesting it
would be interesting to see John Kasich
involved although he's been involved in
Ohio and some horrible anti-choice anti
abortion legislation those are some
ideas uh uh it's a it's a perfectly fair
and realistic question and I think it's
not that Democrats and liberals expect
that Trump would be picking Democrats
and liberals to be in his cabinet but
we're seeing some of the most extreme
buffoons selected here everybody from
Rex Tillerson just an oil industry
Russia friend a neurosurgeon to head up
Housing and Urban Development a guy who
wants to scale up the failed war on
drugs as Attorney General it's all crazy
it's all bizarro world and none of it
makes any sense whatsoever on the bonus
show today the giant panda no longer in
danger now only vulnerable it has been
scaled down in the sort of ranking of
how at in peril certain species are we
will talk about a firefighter who saved
32 people from carbon monoxide symptoms
at
restaurant we will talk about why
producer Pat wasn't here today hint it
has to do with a court case that is all
I will say and will dig into it in more
detail with Rachel on the bonus show
david pakman.com slash membership sign
up today get instant access to the bonus
show